let's start with brexit before the vote
you went to Britain and you talked about
maybe moving 4,000 jobs right since then
you've taken a kind of wait-and-see
attitude to what happens before this
week it's a pleasure to be here exactly
but this for this week Theresa May has
has has has said Britain is not going to
be in the single market it's gonna be in
the customs union you closer to making a
decision about roughly what you would do
not really thrilled she made a speech
and is giving more clarity and trying to
have a transition period and then this
hoping this whole transition period
isn't because what we want it's simply
that we have the ability the time to
move people build systems acquire real
estate it's not up to us if you know the
British people are gonna decide and
they're gonna negotiate with the EU and
when they finish their negotiation we're
gonna know what it means for us we
simply have to accommodate the laws of
the land both to Britain to you and that
will determine how many jobs and how
many people and how many things have to
move well the site the 4,000 was a
estimate the time of Sullivan you know
could be more it could be less depending
and they're just all the same but we
don't want to it's not a threat it's a
fact that we will simply have to
accommodate the new requirements all the
same when she started she has made it
very clear that she is prioritizing
immigration over the single market and
she doesn't want to give a particularly
special deal for financial services
right you're a global bank based in
London you hire a lot of non British
people to work there surely this is you
know generally Britain is heading in the
wrong direction for JPMorgan and for
other banks yeah so one of the things
it's not just as a bank so London is a
fabulous financial center where we have
huge kinds of scale which accrue to the
people of Europe
remember gustar cost but it gets passed
on I'll be the customer if they when
they change the rules when you said we
have to move so those people and yes
it'll reduce jobs there now the Brits
will decide how they want to compete
around the world who the negotiate with
is not up to me it's up to you know the
Prime Minister and the Parliament at
this point at the moment it seems more
likely the big American banks on the
hole might pull jobs back to New York
rather necessarily go taking it it looks
like there will be more job movement
than we would hope for you I kept coming
back to New York as opposed to going to
that we don't know yet it depends with
the lawyers and the equivalency and the
requirements and you know they can put
in the EU converted very stringent rules
which require some of the jobs to move
into the
where they can be a little more flexible
and allow equivalency between the US and
Europe and so it really depends with the
conflict
remember it's 27 nations and so this is
negotiations going to take quite a while
another election coming up this year
France have you factored in the
possibility of a lepen presidency and
what that could do to the European Union
is that one of the worries you have
about this year yeah one of things I
always worry about brags it wasn't just
the effect on Britain the GDP of the UK
etc it was really about what it says so
long-term health of Europe and you know
if you were wishful thinking which I
kind of was a little bit is that that
Brit greg's it would cause the European
Union to look at what went wrong and fix
it because what went wrong is going
wrong for everybody that's just going
wrong for Britain but in some ways it
looks like they're kind of doubling down
so if you like that Europe is not fixing
its problems it's not response to brakes
and so I think you have you're gonna
have constant you have the same
political things about immigration who
controls the laws of the country how
much power goes to Brussels how much in
flexibility and capital labor you're
gonna have so I'm still hoping they do
it but if you have a lepen presidency
and other nations or the eurozone may
not survive and that that is a very
complex thing that's the mistake view of
Europe yeah it's a long term pest in
those videos unless they change unless
they change I think they're gonna have
to change and and to be more competitive
globally and you know they're doing okay
right now by the way you look at the
economy today is going like 1% Plus
which is okay and I say is that respect
for the European people but they're
gonna have to change and you know it may
be forced by politics it may be forced
by new leadership well we'll have to say
are there any leaders inside Europe you
think carry that mandate of change in a
positive direction
I think Angela Merkel is one of the most
confident leader political leaders in
the planet today
you know she's up for election to in a
year or so so but if she has been the
effective ruler of Europe and the
European you've described as one which
is not reformed your faith in her may
not be entirely justified what will say
I mean it's not over I mean there's a
long way to go in this game in my
opinion